[Música]
Y en este momento vamos con nuestra
sección directo a y nos desplazamos
hasta Buenos Aires donde un tribunal
condenó a seis años de prisión a la
vicepresidenta Cristina Fernández de
kirchner además de inhabilitarla de por
vida en el caso tras el caso vitalidad
en el que fue hallada culpable de fraude
al estado sin embargo la también ex
mandataria no irá inmediatamente a
prisión pues su defensa va a recurrir la
condena la ex jefa de estado reiteró su
inocencia y dijo que es esta sentencia
es obra de una mafia judicial para
Estatal vamos a conectar con natalio
cosoy corresponsal de France 24 en la
capital Argentina natalio Cómo recibió
la sociedad esta condena
bueno digamos la primera reacción y está
bien que lo que lo estemos marcando lo
dijiste Desde allí es la de ella la
Cristina Fernández que casi
inmediatamente después de que cerrara el
anuncio y la lectura de esta sentencia
salió muy fuerte a criticar al juzgado
como decías una suerte de mafia judicial
que estaría detrás de esta decisión pero
también por supuesto los sectores
aliados a Cristina Fernández o de que
apoyan a Cristina Fernández primero en
la calle sí apoyos en la calle de
militantes cercanos a ella de
organizaciones políticas cercanas
al cristianismo al frente de todos que
es el partido de gobierno más tarde
también un hilo de tweets del presidente
Alberto Fernández que salió a respaldar
a la vicepresidenta vicepresidenta y a
criticar fuertemente la decisión del
tribunal y hasta ahora estoy haciendo un
repaso de las visiones críticas sobre la
visión del tribunal por el otro lado de
la oposición
fundamentalmente el sector de Juntos por
el cambio el partido del expresidente
Mauricio macri salió a defender la
decisión del tribunal y a decir que era
un ejemplo de no impunidad en Argentina
Es la primera vez que una vicepresidenta
en ejercicio es condenada en un en un
caso de estas características mientras
está en ejercicio de sus funciones así
que bueno una revelación de la
polarización que existe en la sociedad a
través de las voces de dirigentes de uno
y otro lado si uno se pudiera hablar
también en la calle con personas
encontraría versiones de uno y otro lado
reacciones de uno y otro lado natalio
que sigue ahora en este caso
pues interesante Porque Cristina
Fernández tiene un material la
posibilidad como los otros condenados de
luego de la lectura de
los fundamentos de la sentencia que se
va a dar en marzo de 2023 va a poder
apelar primero en una en una instancia
de casación y luego si casación no le da
la razón podría volver otra vez a
elevarlo a la Corte Suprema y pedir que
la Corte Suprema analice su caso y
Determine si es correcto o no el el la
decisión del tribunal esto puede llevar
meses incluso más de un año durante ese
periodo ella No ninguno de los acusados
realmente tiene que cumplir la sentencia
hasta que no es firme firme en última
instancia que en este caso sería la
Corte Suprema hasta que eso no ocurre la
sentencia no debe ser cumplida y hay una
cosa interesante porque ella Además está
cubierta por los fueros que tiene como
vicepresidente es algo que va a perder
el 10 de diciembre cuando complete su
mandato de 2023 y existía la
especulación de que tal vez se
presentaría algún cargo colectivo entre
otras para mantenerlos fueras y ella
dijo en su alocución de hoy claramente
que en 2023 no se va a presentar las
elecciones y que va a estar sin fueros
cuando llegue el 10 de diciembre del
próximo año veremos en qué condiciones
está la causa y qué ocurre En ese
entonces